rosa colindres es una de las
damnificadas por las lluvias que azotan
tegucigalpa desde hace dos meses los
servicios de emergencia la eba actuaron
luego que un derrumbe estuvo a punto de
arrastrar con sus casas
porque iba pasando y pedrito la otra
hija mayor de la que trabaja de un gran
grito me voy a matar a mi mamá tengo una
gerencia de desarrollo humano de la
alcaldía de tegucigalpa las lluvias han
dejado alrededor de mil damnificados 50
familias desplazadas y decenas de casas
destruidas
protección civil aseguró que las
precipitaciones van de 60 a 100
milímetros diarios de lluvia bueno hemos
tenido que
hacer un llamado primero para
notificarles de que si están en riesgo
sus vidas que es lo más importante y
bueno solamente de las tres familias que
estamos evacuando ahorita a una de ellas
tenemos que convencer pese al llamado de
las autoridades hay familias que se
resisten a dejar sus hogares sin un
lugar a donde ir mayra y su madre se
aferran al único sitio que tienen para
vivir aún sabiendo que les puede costar
la vida no podemos nosotros dejar donde
vivimos porque no tenemos dónde ir a
pagar otro lado que se ama más como
luego más seguro pues la comisión
permanente de contingencias mantiene la
alerta verde o de prevención para varios
departamentos ante la amenaza de nuevas
precipitaciones
la alcaldía de tegucigalpa reactivo
cuatro albergues para atender a las
familias damnificadas
el gobierno asignó un presupuesto anual
de casi 10 millones de dólares para
atenderlas
a nivel nacional